Kids died a lot.
Yeah.
Then Dad died from injury and sickness
and a lot of people died from sickness,
you know,
no vaccines when you just said the mercy.
And then also it's the
beginning of agriculture.
So all these diseases are emerging that
we don't have immune systems for it
because they're being, they're being
jumped from like they're there,
they're jumping from pigs to people.
They're jumping from
chickens and birds to people.
That's where the source of most of
these pandemic diseases come from.
It comes from large scale agriculture.
Those funky pigs all tucked
together in these little cages.
That doesn't come for free.
Like there's some demons are being brewed
in that mix. Yeah. Like this, this,
what was this? What was the
source of, um, the Spanish flu,
which I think was the most
deadly epidemic in u s history.
Oh, is that right? It was international
to, was international for sure.
I think for sure it was the most
deadly epidemic in the u s yeah.
But I think he came,
I don't think it came from Spain.
I think I want to say it came
from somewhere around Virginia.
Does that bullshit. This is going
to take time probably in New Jersey.
I feel like it came from
some sort of farm situation.
I don't know why I feel like,
I'm guessing that surprised it's not
more of that now because you see some of
these like pig farms and they have links.
There are lakes of waste.
If you seen the drone footage, is that
what we're talking about? Oh my God.
Some guy fluid, you know, cause
they have these ag gag laws,
which apparently one of them just got
shot down a, somebody sent me an email
that some, maybe it was Idaho
or Iowa, one of those places.
One was I states that uh,
the uh,
ag gag laws got shutdown.
The AG gag laws are safe.
You are working in a slaughterhouse
when you saw horrific conditions,
you got your cell phone out, you
filmed it, you could get prosecuted,
you would go to jail,
you could be sued because if walking,
all those documentaries that came out.
Well it's the,
I think those ag gag laws existed as soon
as they figured out that people could
film thing. You know, because a few people
released videos of her and it looked,
those ag gag laws kept,
you know,
kept people from talking about a
lot of creepy shit like this video.
If you see this video,
this guy decided since no one's
going to give him access to film,
the place openly,
she's gonna fly over it.
So he flew over with a drone Spanish
flu thing. Okay. For many years,
medical historians and epidemiologists
hypothesize that the outbreak could have
started in a British army
base in [inaudible] France
or at Fort Riley in Kansas
where the first American cases of the
new strain of flu were recorded in March
of 1918 more recently,
experts have experts have
proposed a third hypothesis.
The Spanish flu originated somewhere in
northern China in late 1917 and swiftly
move to eastern Europe within
140,000 Chinese laborers and,
uh,
the French and British
governments recruited to
perform manual labor to free up
the troops for war time duty. Wow.
Yeah. I think more people died of that.
Then they die then died
in world war one fifth.
So 50 million people were
killed because of this damn,
whoa.
Just think about courses.
A 50 million people looking at
reclaiming. Look at this. It says,
claiming more lives in a single year than
either the first world war or the four
year long black death,
bubonic plague outbreak that swept
Europe and Asia in the Middle Ages.
And this is one that, for whatever
reason, people talk about the plague.
They talk about the bubonic
plague. Look, everyone's heard of,
but no one talks about the Spanish
flu. Like that's a rare, it's not.
It doesn't get brought up that often.
If you see this number,
this number of people die, 50
million people in a year, in a year.
Man. People talk about how bad
that we're saying is right now,
but that's not what they're saying.
They're saying that killed more lives
in a single year than either the first
world war or the four year long
black death may have killed,
and that he may have kept one third
of the population was sick with it.
At least they didn't all die.
God Damn.